et c'était l'autre événement majeur du
week-end l'accueille triomphale samedi
des rugbymen irlandais à Tours ça a
commencé par une représentation publique
des joueurs devant 12000 spectateurs au
stade de la Vallée du Cher le 15 du
Trèfle qui s'est ensuite rendu au Grand
Théâtre cette fois en costume cravatée
en cascade vous allez le découvrir
résumé de cette journée avec Léa Turquie
[Musique]
à peine arrivé en France est déjà dans
l'ambiance les tours enjoux savent être
accueillants 12500 personnes se sont
réunies pour acclamer le 15 du Trèfle un
stade de la Vallée du Cher rempli
d'amoureux du rugby avec les yeux qui
brillent genre passionné de rugby donc
pour moi c'est c'est l'apothéose quoi
c'est déjà une belle une belle nation du
rugby c'est la meilleure assurance en ce
moment donc c'est vraiment sympa de les
voir j'aime bien
[Musique]
le rut je viens de dire Landes et
j'habite ici en Touraine maintenant
depuis 4 ans et j'adore le rugby un
grand jour pour moi
pourtant l'unique entraînement public de
l'équipe irlandaise a été pour le moins
furtif au bout de 45 minutes rideau les
joueurs retournent dans les vestiaires
en cause un problème avec la pelouse du
stade a pris à la dernière minute par la
ville de Tours finalement les conditions
climatiques des derniers jours ont fait
que le terrain était pas satisfaisant
pour l'équipe irlandaise et donc ils ont
décidé de ne pas faire un entraînement
classique je pense c'était quand même un
beau moment de rencontre entre l'équipe
irlandaise et les tourangères et les
tours en jeu
conséquence animation et dédicace pour
rattraper le coup mais forcément il
reste quelques déceptions
on est un petit peu déçu effectivement
c'était un vrai moment de partage et de
plaisir voilà c'était un peu court j'ai
jamais assez quand on a le staff
irlandais mais bon c'est toujours un
moment important et les voir aussi près
enfin voilà ça ça fait chaud au coeur du
côté des joueurs la journée n'est pas
finie direction le Grand Théâtre de
Tours pour la cérémonie d'accueil
officielle dite des Caps chaque joueur
se voit remettre une casquette symbole
traditionnelle de sa participation à la
Coupe du monde le tout toujours dans une
atmosphère chaleureuse à la française
l'accueil des tours enjoux a été génial
on espère qu'ils vont rester derrière
nous et qu'on va pouvoir compter sur ce
soutien en France
on sait combien on est chanceux d'être
ici on est aussi ravis d'être à tour
pour cette escale en espérant qu'elle
soit longue
les Irlandais sont maintenant dans les
starting blocks top départ des matchs le
samedi 9 septembre à 15h30 contre la
Roumanie